messieurs bonjour merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france france 4 buzz
cette mobilisation des jd jaune
intervient alors qu hier nous apprenions
que le gouvernement va fournir 100 euros
à tous les français à toutes les
personnes qui touchent moins de 2000
euros par mois que pensez vous de cette
mesure
le chose la première
on sort des mesures technocratiques des
mesures bureaucratiques pour aller vers
une mesure simple générale universelle
100 euros c'est simple c'est rapide et
c'est efficace et la deuxième c'est que
j'ai bien entendu évidemment les
protestataires et je respecte tout à
fait ce qu'ils disent mais pour autant
si vous calculer objectivement
ce que coûte l'augmentation actuelle du
carburant sur un réservoir de 40 litres
de la coûte entre 4 et 6 euros de plus à
plein de carburant selon que l'on
circule au gasoil ont au super sans
plomb 95 ce qui signifie au delà
représente entre 17 et 23 plein entre 17
et 23 augmentation du plein alors ça
n'est pas assez ça ne sera jamais assez
mais moi ce que ce dont devrait juillet
ce dont je félicite la majorité
présidentielle c'est d'avoir réagi vite
d'avoir réagi de façon juste parce que
si on avait baissé les taxes d'abord sur
était-il l'eau ç'aurait été techniques
et bureaucratiques et ensuite cela
aurait profité à tout le monde sans
redistribution la la le chèque de saint
bon profil or aux classes moyennes aux
personnes qui ont des difficultés et non
par l ceux qui sont les plus favorisés
sont contrairement à ce que l'on dira
c'est une véritable mesure depuis crise
sociale françois cocq je vous laisse à
rebondir sur les propos de monsieur 80e
angers reprendre le début une mesure
simple mesure efficace une mesure rapide
qu'en pensez vous
une mesure rapide j'ai du mal à avoir
mon nom dans quel
esprit mesure et rapide que le
gouvernement n'at-il pas au préalable
bloquer les prix plutôt que d'attendre
qu'ils explosent aujourd'hui il serait
simple aujourd'hui de bloquer les prix
mais au moment où il était encore à un
niveau qui était soutenable pour le
quotidien des gens et pas au niveau
actuel ça c'est la première chose le
gouvernement a tardé et d'ailleurs il a
encore passé plusieurs jours à mettre en
scène les annonces qui ont été celles de
monsieur castex jeudi soir deuxièmement
c'est une broutille imaginez bien quand
même que cela représente ses seins ce
chèque de 100 euros 27 centimes par jour
la baisse des taxes qu évoquer mon
interlocuteur elle aurait un autre et un
autre une autre dimension voyez la tva
sur l'essence la tva représente
aujourd'hui un peu plus de 20 centimes
par litre si on l'a baissé de 20% à 7 et
8% il y aurait 20 centimes par litre qui
alors blanc de 27 centimes par litre
elle passerait à 7 centimes donc y
aurait 20 centimes qui serait dans la
dans la poche du consommateur et qui
seraient épargnées et bien c'est 20
centimes par litre faites le compte vous
aussi en nombre de plaintes puisque
c'est ce que c'est ce que propose mon
interlocuteur ça vous fait une sacrée
différence et c'est autre chose que les
100 euros qui sont finalement rien
d'autre que la nouvelle façon de faire
campagne à inventer monsieur macron vous
savez avant quand on faisait de la
politique ont distribué des tracts
électoraux et bien désormais monsieur
macron distribuer des chèques d'une
certaine façon il est en train de monter
l'achat de votes et légaliser ou l'abus
de bien social légal et bien c'est là où
nous en sommes aujourd'hui avec cette
façon de faire de la politique et les
françaises et les français ne s'y
retrouvent pas un dernier mot parce
qu'on a un choix de raison à faire sur
cette question du chèque il faut bien
voir que cette question du chèque soit
elle s'adresse aux plus pauvres des plus
pauvres ce qui est le cas du chèque
énergie vous avez vu l'augmentation de
l'énergie au delà de la question de
l'essence cette question de l'énergie
fait que l'augmentation par foyer est
d'environ entre 600 et 700 euros le
chèque d'énergie maxi al pour une année
pointe à 324 euros et encore pour les
gens qui gagnent moins de 6000 euros par
an et tous ceux qui gagnent plus de
10000 euros par an ne touche absolument
rien donc cette question du chèque
aujourd'hui une règle certainement pas
la question si on veut faire de la
redistribution comme l'évoqué mon
interlocuteur la rue distribution ça
passe par le fait de répartir autrement
la manne et le gâteau est d'abord
puisqu'on cherche de l'argent par
récupérer les 4 milliards d'euros qui
sont ceux de la suppression de l' isf
qui est aujourd'hui le point de départ
et le point d'arrivée du quinquennat de
monsieur macron allons dans ce cas là
vers une fiscalité plus juste plus
progressive et en taxant celles et ceux
qui aujourd'hui sont les plus épargnés à
savoir les plus riches france 4 buzz
vous laisse répondre
que difficile de répondre à tant
d'outrance sous le quinquennat de france
ô l'homme noir noboa était ministre
l'insee a démontré que le pouvoir
d'achat des français a augmenté de 0 %
sous le quinquennat d'emmanuel macron il
a augmenté de 4% alors il y a des
difficultés évidemment mais
contrairement à ce que répètent un
mantra une certaine gauche radicaliser
et l'extrême gauche emmanuel macron
n'est pas le président des riches et ce
chèque de 100 euros destinée aux
français les plus modestes et qui a la
preuve qu'il y a une volonté
redistributrice alors on vous dira
toujours que ça n'est pas assez mais la
10ème la diminution des taxes cela
profite aussi aux plus riches et on vous
aurait dit encore une fois que c'était
le président des riches c'est tout
simple
vous êtes un porte parole d'arnaud
montebourg qui a plusieurs propositions
pour augmenter le pouvoir d'achat des
français je sens qu'elle fontanes et
quels sont les leviers qu'il compte
actionnaires
oui parce que là nous sommes en train de
parler des mesures d'urgence qui arrive
finalement après là bas après la
bataille il faudrait aujourd'hui des
mesures de structures qui sont celles
qui ne sont pas intervenus pendant ce
quinquennat pas plus que dans les
quelques années à précédent d'ailleurs
je vous fais remarquer que c'est sur la
base de ces désaccords stratégiques car
mon hambourg a acquitté le
le gouvernement qui était présidée par
par monsieur par monsieur hollande alors
les propositions d'arnaud montebourg
elles sont simples d'abord effectivement
une augmentation des salaires ça veut
dire une augmentation immédiatement du
smic de 10% et un grenelle des salaires
pour par branches discuter d'une
augmentation de tous les salaires en
dessous de 2000 euros ça c'est la
première chose à faire est dans la
fonction publique bien évidemment un
rattrapage de la même manière qui
passera par l'augmentation du point
d'indicé puisque comme vous le savez les
salaires sont gelés depuis 2010 ce qui
est une aberration l'augmentation du
pouvoir d'achat qui est évoqué cdc des
chiffres macro qui sont macroéconomiques
qui sont évoqués je vous mets au défi
d'aller voir les français et de leur
dire que leur pouvoir d'achat a évoqué
ce n'est pas la réalité de leur
quotidien regardez les fils de les
filles qui s'allonge devant le secours
populaire où les les restaurants du
coeur il y a là une autre réalité que
celle qui est donnée par par les
chiffres et puis il ya besoin je le
disais aujourd'hui pour redonner du
pouvoir d'achat de rétablir une vraie
fiscalité ce qui n'est absolument pas le
cas aujourd'hui une fiscalité plus
progressive
j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure le fait de
rétablir liée à celle qui était
supprimée par rapport à monsieur macro
ça serait la première chose peut-être à
faire pour redonner du sens envoyer un
signal politique pour faire un petit peu
sens commun parce qu on a quand même de
plus en plus l'impression et ça a été le
sentiment général pendant ce quinquennat
qui a lu un séparatisme des riches
prendre quatre buts est ce que vous
comprenez justement c'est en tout cas
ces manifestants qu'on entend lors des
mobilisations gilet jaune qui parle
d'une précarité qui n'arrêtent pas
d'augmenter est ce que vous comprenez ce
qu'il essaye de dire mais madame je
comprends tout cas c'est parce que je
vis dans le bassin minier du nord je
suis élu d'un bassin minier du nord et
je comprends tout à fait ce que
ressentent les français qui sont dans la
difficulté et c'est tout autre chose que
ce que décrivent les populistes quel que
soit le bord du populisme il ressemble
des difficultés oui et nous devons y
répondre par une juste redistribution
une réforme fiscale d'ampleur
la faire mais rétablir l'impôt sur les
grandes fortunes pour le répartir entre
l'ensemble des français bien ça fera un
plein d'essence elle nous dira encore
que ça n'est pas assez donc je pense que
oui des réformes structurelles il faut
en faire les crises que nous avons
connues et particulièrement évidemment
la crise sanitaire
empêcher malheureusement la majorité de
pouvoir mener à bien ses réformes mais
j'espère que dans un prochain mandat
nous aurons le temps de travailler en
profondeur et et là je parle vraiment en
militants centristes dans un esprit de
concorde et techniques
le soin quand qu'on va parler de
l'actualité du jour c'est ce retour des
gilet jaune bien qu'il n'y ait jamais
vraiment en disparition c'est à quelques
mois de la présidentielle est ce que le
mouvement aura une résonance
particulière cette année
oui tout simplement ce parce que vous
venez de le dire nous approchons de
l'élection présidentielle et qu on vient
de le dire et le reconnaître malgré lui
mon interlocuteur finalement il vient
d'y avoir un quinquennat pour rien de la
part de monsieur macron on nous dit il
faudrait donner un deuxième mandat à
monsieur macro pour me faire et mettre
en oeuvre les réformes qu'il n'a pas
fait mais que ne l'at il pas fait depuis
le début de ce de ce quinquennat je vous
le dis la première est fautif réformes
qu'il a fait ça a été de supprimer l isf
et sap a été de faire une grande mesure
de pour transformer l'impôt sur le
revenu et le rendre plus progressif dont
bien évidemment les gilet jaune
reviennent sur le devant de la scène et
noté qu'il revienne sur le devant de la
scène avec les deux mêmes préoccupations
qui étaient celles qui sont intervenus à
l'automne 2010 8 à savoir d'un côté la
question sociale et puis de l'autre côté
la question démocratique souvenez-vous
que en 2018 les gens défilent et déjà
sur les ronds points avec leur carte
électorale à la main en demandant
finalement que ce qu'on leur avait vendu
comme programme politique soit enfin
adoptée et mise en oeuvre et il ne s'y
retrouver pas il y avait donc un hiatus
de légitimité est apparu à ce moment là
et bien ce que disent les gens
aujourd'hui c'est que le gouvernement
d'une certaine façon les mules tient
dans un état de privations c'est une
forme de torture aux politiques et
politiciennes qui étaient mises en
oeuvre ou on sent bien que le
gouvernement distribue des des omon
plutôt que de régler la question et
d'essayer régler la question en
profondeur parce que ils se retrouvent
dans une vision globale de la société ou
celles et ceux qui sont les plus faibles
les plus fragiles mais s'agissait aussi
dont l'utilité sociale des métiers et la
plus importante doivent être des laissés
pour compte dans la tête de monsieur
macron une a eu de cesse de le dire
durant tout son mandat avec des mots
extrêmement méprisant et bien c'est un
petit peu ça qui ressurgit aujourd'hui à
quelque à quelques mois de l'élection
présidentielle
et ce souffle populaire il il a été un
peu amenuisé atténuée par la crise
sanitaire parce que nous avons vécu un
épisode extrêmement douloureux nous
sommes rentrés dans l'ère peut-être des
solidarités replier où on a essayé de
prendre soin plus particulièrement de
nous autres et de ceux qui sont les plus
proches de nous eh bien aujourd'hui
c'est espèce de bulle de protection
c'est solidarité aux pieds elle est si
de retrouver de l'oxygène de retrouver
de l'allant pour refaire corps communs
pour devenir ce que nous sommes nous
autres français un corps politique dit
cherche à reprendre le contrôle est
âprement être maître de la discipline
françois cocq merci à vous vous êtes
porte parole d'arnaud montebourg france
4 robots vous êtes délégué des portes à
départemental du modem merci à vous
également d'avoir et en direct avec mon
sur rt france